right with aaron rodgers the train's
pulling into the station that's right
far closer to the end in the beginning
you're going to give up a year you're
going to give up half a year you know
the carson palmer situation is the one
that gets mentioned most often in
comparison to rogers because palmer was
done with the bengals the owner was
hard-headed the owner said go ahead and
rot i don't care and he sat and he sat
and he sat until a fluke broken
collarbone yeah suffered by jason
campbell opened the door to multiple
first-round picks problem solved but to
get there
carson palmer had to sit out six weeks
of the season does rogers even want to
do that does he want to miss one game
given that he's only got four years left
so whatever this plan is if it entails
playing in 2021
they they they need to
they need to do something more
i think
to get the point across and this gets
back to the
message i've been sending ever since
thursday friday when this all first came
up
you got to tell us what you want you got
to let everyone know what you want uh
mike i don't play games anymore you got
to say what you want yeah if you're
going to get what you want you got to
say what you want yeah that's right that
that to me is where it's the biggest
question of the whole the whole scenario
i mean i'm with you i think that's it
you've kind of said this for a long long
time i give you a lot of credit uh i
mean i think your read is right yeah
rogers is that kind of guy that he
doesn't want to be the bad guy he
doesn't want to do that well okay that's
fine and dandy but for right now in this
situation the way you just explained it
like
is rogers willing to get his hands dirty
and like kind of look like a jerk for a
little while with the green bay packer
fan base and everything like that
to
basically force a move somewhere else is
he willing to do that and and i really
don't know it's it's odd like i felt
like i felt like with deshawn watson or
russell wilson like
i i had a feeling of like you know what
when they need to be the bad guy they'll
do it i don't know if rogers has it in
them to do it and that that's the big
question what do you feel about that
i think he'll do what he ever has to do
today to the fans
i think he will do some major league
pandering to the fans at the appropriate
time whether that's financial
contributions
billboards
open letters in the milwaukee journal
sentence okay whatever he has to do it
would be a political campaign where he
panders to the fans and bends over
backwards to get them on his side but do
you think he'll go scorch earth though
do you think he'll go scorched earth on
green bay though to make that happen and
kind of force their hand and really go
like hey i'm i'm done i'm serious i'm
out of here i don't want to do that you
know he's gonna have to say some of
those things publicly too and probably
make this a little bit messier and then
do what you said and i'm just not sure
if he's willing to do that first part
like what do you think about that
i think that's his nuclear option that
he's yeah he's moving his finger closer
yeah right right
but i'm not sure he's ever going to
press
right i'm not sure he's ever going to do
it he wants to try to get out without
half having to actually
go that far
because at that point it really does
increase the possibility that fans will
turn on him no matter what he does to
pander to them and i think that that's
where the packers are calling his bluff
the most it's not just go ahead and sit
out it's go ahead go ahead and go
scorched earth we dare you yeah to take
us on we're the packers community owned
you take on us you're taking on the fans
necessarily anyone who has that framed
stock certificate on the wall in their
den you're taking them on too that's how
i could see the packers couching it and
just daring him
to turn it into a big fight because they
ultimately think he won't because that's
the read they have on him that's i still
think
mark murphy's the guy who's the puppet
master here working this thing out
keeping aaron rodgers just upset enough
so he plays well but not so upset that
he upsets the apple cart and now he's
trying to upset the apple cart and
murphy thinks he won't do it when push
comes to shove you won't do it however
teammates are starting to get the
message devonte adams a cryptic tweet
from monday but you know
either he's sending a message about the
situation or he's completely and totally
tone deaf to the broader circumstances
of his life right now and that happens
from time to time with athletes they
claim oh i wasn't talking about that 600
pound block of limburger cheese sitting
in the living room even though i was got
to appreciate what you got while you got
it devonte adams said possibly a message
to himself
seriously that's what i was yeah right
you know or or a message to packers fans
i mean multiple levels and layers of
message chris complicated by the fact
that aaron rodgers saw that tweet and
he's one of the 53 000 plus who clicked
the like button boom so
uh yes yeah see it's gonna it's gonna
continue to play this way for aaron
rodgers he's gonna try to do it just be
an irritant yeah just passive aggressive
yeah yes
and and all it takes is that one day
that mark murphy says all right i've had
i've just had enough
i'm too old for this crap
let's just look we're gonna feel better
to be done with this guy
because he's never going to come at us
the way that we want it's going to
constantly be sniping
and these backhanded comments right and
he's going to be stirring and
and i think he's hoping to shake their
resolve and then there will be a point
and i'm sure he's got it all mapped out
all planned out he had last thursday
planned out he's he's probably got
various steps and strategies up until
the first day of training camp up until
the first day of the regular season
up until the trade deadline she's got it
all mapped out and all planned out see
that's when everyone thinks you're
really smart they're going to assume
that you're really smart and they're
going to assume that you're really
calculated that you're strategic and i
consider that a compliment yeah you got
to have a plan for your life sure and i
think aaron rodgers has a plan for this
season and he's working his way through
the steps and i think he's he's in the
let's just irritate them as much as i
can so they'll throw their hands in the
air and trade it does seem like yeah
he's in that phase i mean i'm i'm i
agree with you in the fact that he
probably does have a little yeah some
some sort of plan a plan of attack here
there's no doubt here here's one that i
keep coming back to in this whole
situation mike and maybe you got a good
thought on it or you know something that
i don't but like where
wha why
why do this
now
why why do it now that's where i come
back to it to where like at first i
didn't want to believe maybe rogers was
behind some of this stuff that got
released you know late last week and all
of that
my tune has changed obviously but what
i'm just like confused about from his
side of this right and you know you
don't want to be there
why why do it at the draft and i know
there's the jordan love last year and
maybe it's payback but if you really
want out of there
why not make this known as soon as the
season was over you know you would have
had lots of options and things like that
and really been able to figure out or
steer your boat in the direction you
wanted to go as far as the team you
wanted to play for i mean he really
closed some options out i have a hard
time thinking like hey the new england
patriots were they involved with aaron
rodgers if they knew he was available
you know late february early march i i
bet you they would have he would have
had a whole bunch of other options
that's where i don't get it from his his
camp or his side mike
well i think the rams are the most
significant example yeah and remember
two things sam farmer of the la times
reported
that the rams called the packers and the
packers shot that down because they
didn't want it to become a thing the way
that russell wilson was a thing at the
same time and number two at one point
les sneed used the phrase beautiful
mystery in a different context
altogether you are right thinking what's
he up to
you're right i remember this i i think
this and this comes back to the point we
were just discussing a few minutes ago
about when and if aaron rodgers is
willing to go scorched earth and be the
bad guy i think his plan
from
end of season until draft yeah was to
try
to make it all happen quietly and behind
the scenes without it becoming public
right without it looking like he's the
one that wanted out and i also think
that part of that was so he could stake
out some real estate if he got traded
say what me
wouldn't me
i i wouldn't me
wouldn't me i didn't do it i didn't ask
for it right you know i i would that
surprise us no if that was what the plan
was and he does get traded he acts like
hey you know they're just they're just
implementing their plan they we all knew
this day was coming the moment they
drafted jordan love i mean there'd be
something he could say to spin it back
around on them and they're not going to
get into a street fight with him
especially after they've traded him
he'll be able to say whatever he wants
yeah you're right so i think that was
the plan three months to get them to do
it and they kept digging in you know
they went out there three times i'm
telling you that
they went out there right yeah maybe
more to try to get his feathers
unruffled and he you know he he
held firm
and and i think
they
they called his bluff maybe they knew
yeah maybe he told them hey guys here's
how it's going to go down
you don't trade me
you're going to find out
first day of the draft it's all going to
hit just mark my words it's all going to
hit that i want out get ready for it
giving you fair notice you're gonna have
a distraction that gets dropped right on
your plate as you're getting ready for
the draft this is all gonna start to
come out you have until then to make it
happen if it doesn't happen by then
the world is gonna know
that i want out and they may have
thought baloney baloney you're not gonna
do that we know how you operate now now
look this is far more candid of a
communication
here than maybe what they had it was far
more subtle i assume but
the the events
would tend to suggest
that he had that plan in mind he gave
them that three months to do it they
didn't do it and he acted on his threat
now the question is what else is he
threatened to do
and will they continue
to not believe it'll keep doing it and i
think that's why we're at that point
where
are
are they going to call his bluff all the
way to the point where he goes scorched
earth so i think that answers the
question they just decided
that yeah wouldn't
you're right wouldn't make it known that
he wants out so they didn't feel
compelled to trade him yeah and now
they're dealing with it and then now i
mean listen now i mean dealing with it
but again i think they're in phase two
of like let's call his bluff again i
don't think he'll go any more serious
than what he just did this past weekend
and i i don't know yeah i have a hard
time believing he will too
uh i do you know i mean hey at basically
how do you walk this back though how do
you tuck tail between your legs and show
up after all this is out there how do
you do it he's a very prideful person
yeah
how and that's there's nothing wrong
with that he just is a lot of guys
playing in the nfl are very prideful how
do you say oh well they got me
i yield take the king and knock it over
you win i i i just don't see him doing
that i i i know well i could see him
kind of finagling away of hey i'm not
yeah there's things i didn't like and
i'm not happy and he'll find a way he's
very smart as we've seen in that in the
past i mean you've mentioned it
i think he can probably if he does
decide to walk it back he'll find the
right way and tuned to do it he will
you're right and he'll probably
mike you make a good point too he'll
probably do some charity stuff and
things like that to lessen the blood of
everything as well with it he is very
calculated there's no denying that i
mean the other thing i just come back to
is you know hey one is he willing to go
scorched earth and make this a real
public fight and really you know squeeze
the green bay packers hey number two you
know i know there's still going to be
teams that are willing to trade for him
right now or things like that he is
aaron rodgers but man so many of these
teams have already made their bed and
are kind of getting cozy and sleeping
and going like this is our team this
year you know so like i said he took
those options away and then the biggest
thing to me here too is is he just
man are you willing again as much as i
get disappointed with green bay and not
going all in on rogers
are you really gonna
you know
give away or leave a team that's you
know on the cusp of super bowl yeah
maybe maybe not really a legit super
bowl contender without aaron rodgers but
still
he's got to be thinking like man we i
mean we were this close last year we
could get back there's no doubt we could
win it you know you're really gonna give
that away like you said at the end of
your career maybe three four five years
left we're really towards the end of the
prime and special things that's where
and i know he's aware of legacy and he
wants to be you know the goat and all
those type of things that's where i just
i i i don't know if he's gonna be
willing to retire or just totally walk
away and give that away i just can't
imagine him doing that
well there's two different things
there's retirement and giving up the
rest of your career and then there's
trying to finagle a path to denver where
who knows how good that team could be
that's the team constituted if aaron
rodgers gets plugged in as the
quarterback automatically there's a risk
there but there's a hell of a potential
reward
there's a lot that you said that caught
my attention and one of the things and
matt casey mentioned this in my ear
while you were talking as it relates to
the path back to green bay we could see
a situation where aaron rodgers as part
of the broader effort to win the fan
base say
basically
yes there are issues between me and the
front office there are no issues between
me and matt laflin yes there are no
issues between me and the team there are
the players there are no issues between
me
and the fans so i'm coming back
to do this right i'm coming back to do
everything i can to deliver a super bowl
we'll deal with my issues with the front
office after the season because if you
frame it that way yeah do it just right
right
then as he wins games he rallies support
it becomes like a wheelchair yeah fans
deserve another title
i'm gonna do it for you guys
where the fans get caught in the middle
of it and the two parties involved are
manipulating them and there's nothing
the front office can do to manipulate
them during the regular season if rogers
comes back and he's more motivated than
ever with each victory with each step
they get closer and closer to the super
bowl
they they
are
are on his side and they see his side
and they become
converted to the idea if they aren't
already that uh that the team is in the
wrong the front office is in the wrong
and rogers is in the right the problem
is
right now what's unfolded since last
thursday
there are some fans at least the ones i
deal with anecdotally that have been
yelling at me via email all caps
screaming at my eyeballs for years that
the packers uh are right and that and
that why are you trying to create
trouble and you're wrong about aaron
rodgers and now they're starting to kind
of
pivot the other way they're going yeah
they're they're looking at it right you
mean they're going
to rogers yeah i agree i was going to
say like making a mess no doubt i agree
the the the public opinion has swayed
back to where early last week you know
we actually had this conversation i
think a little bit where i just went man
i think if rogers wanted to do something
or anything like that if he did it the
right way you know public opinion's on
his side but it's not anymore it's
definitely not it's it's gone the other
way he i do think he angered people not
only green bay fans that this became an
issue and everything like this but just
even just the normal nfl fan i think
feels a little bitter towards rogers
that he kind of like hijacked the the
draft weekend to a degree you know it's
gonna come off and look a little selfish
to to those people the casual fan things
like that and yeah i don't i don't think
he's you know in in favor with the
public here or up in green bay with the
way it looks over the last four or five
days
let me say this as the owner and
operator of an nfl-based media outlet i
have no complaints i have none
whatsoever keep it coming aaron rodgers
keep doing whatever it is that you have
to do
in order to make this
news continue because it's great for our
business that's for sure it's not great
for the betting business the folks at
points bet have removed the over under
wind totals for the packers and
the denver broncos yeah
so man how about that yeah well
and what's that tell you that tells you
that somebody somewhere knows that if
this is going to go down it's not going
to be the raiders it's definitely not
going to be the 49ers at this point it's
going to be the broncos the three teams
that he's had on his private wish list
for i don't know how long at least days
maybe weeks 49ers raiders broncos maybe
the rams right
you know
the thinking is he wants to get to the
west coast yes the packers aren't going
to keep him in the conference i i think
folks have started to come to that
conclusion and there's no other spot
right now right although
you mentioned rosters being set i think
teams would yes i know i said that too
but yeah you're right it's roger so
they're still gonna do it right yeah
yeah but it's just you know they're just
getting cozy in the bed they made is
what i was kind of saying to where
they're gonna be like man we just set
our team but okay you're right they're
still gonna call it's aaron rodgers
let me ask you this yeah we made the
point last week how jeopardy
became sort of a pawn in this chess
match between rogers and the packers and
you wonder at what point the folks at
jeopardy are watching this saying
is this a guy we really want to be
dealing with for the next 30 years right
do we want to be dealing with do we want
turd ferguson
you never know when it's going to flip
to turd ferguson that's the problem
right
what if you're one of these other teams
and you know you've heard
about they know aaron rodgers a little
prickly a little hard to deal with yeah
is he so good that you just don't care
right that's it mike everybody knows
they they know what aaron rodgers is
there's there's no doubt about that i've
had this conversation with enough people
over the last few years in the nfl that
yes
you know it's hey good guy smart guy
little different you know gonna
challenge you gonna question everything
you do all those type of things yeah it
could be a little weird to coach here
and there but damn he's aaron rodgers
and he's good and that's what it's gonna
come back down to when it all you know
boils down to the the the point at hand
here but like the broncos thing yeah
that's the one i look at mike and i'll
say this again i'm not into breaking
news or doing anything like this but i
think i did tell you yeah the broncos
were a team about four or five weeks ago
i had heard from somebody i really trust
in the nfl that
was associated with rogers now i've i
understood it as it was something that
would happen after the 2021 season that
that would be the team that might make a
play for him and he had his eye on them
so it was you know
a natural fit that way but it makes
sense we talked about it a little last
week that defense those weapons
everything like that and hey if the
dolphins were involved in the desean
watson conversation they still got a
whole damn
crapload of picks they can trade away if
they really want to make a play here for
aaron rodgers too so those are two teams
that at least just jump out to me at
face value to say if they want to get it
done they can get it done
one big question becomes how intent he
is on being west of texas because there
aren't a whole lot of options you got
the chargers no the rams no the seahawks
i still think john schneider packers
shareholder well should entertain the
possibility of a flip-flop of russell
wilson seriously rogers i still think
that that's worth considering because it
solves both teams problems it does
although
it introduces different problems for
both teams as well the packers would
have to give russell wilson at some
point a gigantic contract and the
seahawks would have to assume whatever
issues the packers have because i have a
feeling john schneider runs the seahawks
the same way
that that the packers run the packers
because that's that's where he grew up
in the business so why do i want a guy
that has an issue with the front office
when i run my front office kind of the
same way the packers run theirs yeah no
i mean it's a valid point it is you know
it's it's different people at least they
haven't scarred him like the packers
front office so you know again it is an
interesting thought i have thought about
it too i brought it up on my podcast
yesterday just going
i mean if they really don't want
you know wilson and they really don't
want rogers yeah i mean well you could
you can make it real easy make the flip
you're right you got to worry about the
contract situation with wilson that's
going to rise here and then with rogers
where you'd be different there is you
just have to go well you know i don't
know how long he'll be here for us
that'll be the big the big thing so
they'll both have their issues to deal
with but it does make sense at a base
level there's no doubt i just do you
think either team would be willing to do
that uh i just i can't imagine
i think it's going to take a lot of work
because you're trading one problem for
another it's just a different problem
yeah that's the reality and i also think
there's a broader
issue at play here
as nfl teams try to resist the
proliferation of the nba mindset how you
have players who are taking over their
careers right and i think the league at
large the teams generally are looking at
this saying this isn't good for anybody
if players have this much power right so
i think that's part of the resistance
too that would go between seattle and
green bay because yeah you'd be
you'd be getting a different quarterback
to plug in but you also would be for two
major players giving them what they want
and pushing the pendulum closer and
closer to nba not nfl which i don't
think the teams want
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports